okay we'll do it live live let's see
your tunes in at 126 in the morning can
we pull viewership assisting Lee an hour
anyone tuned in
will anyone tune it good time to be in
anyone tuning there's no horton hears it
oh yeah what Peter would realize Nate
different alright hey guys so you can oh
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey let's
record this on the actual camera -
alright we're about to film for life
we're gonna be okay there's a there's a
trailer and there's an international
that I hear is pretty bombed - okay so
hey guys it's Greg Alva here we're
shooting to the camera - we're also live
streaming this right now it's better
because for you guys on the livestream
you won't be able to see the trailer
won't be playing with us so we're
shooting it on our camera as well but I
I'm really tired it's 1:30 in the
morning right now he's just got done
filming Pirates of the King Pirates of
the Caribbean 3 which is exhausting and
I want to go to bed soon but I was like
we got to watch this spider-man
homecoming trailer while we're together
right now that just dropped
alright so losing sleep over people you
guys won't be able to see the trailer
but you can hear it with us
when we when I actually cut up something
then you'll you'll see it's kind of
weird hopping back four three two camera
but if you watch them side by side
eventually we'll make eye contact on
both plants alright here we go John
yes a little bottom house nothing
missing a little bit for us but it's
okay see-through
finally here we go free evening Peter oh
you have 576 possible of sugar
combination what whoa keep that suit
yeah
dunfin me Wednesday retreat well next
mission we'll call you alright it's not
a hug can describe the tough way
oh there yet okay good luck keep showing
that scene
Here Come today I can't tonight I got
the Starkey to ship what's up guys this
is my there's my report for tonight I
stopped the grand theft bicycle hey
could you do me a favor hold on I helped
us old lady and she bought me a churro
so that was nice you guys are the real
event just hope gives it away you've
been working on
[Music]
he's welcome those crazy dangerous
listen Peter the people who handle this
sort of thing can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man sir
activating parachute
the world's changing boys time we change
too
I can't prove myself vivo Spanish quiz
you gotta get better at this part of it
dog lover
oh I'm intimidated oh whoa
[Music]
oh yeah
Oh God what are you hiding
Peter
hmm just getting anger by
[Music]
there's a ton of other subsystems in
here but Paul disabled by the training
wheels protocols because mister start
treating you like a kid you are a kid
yeah can you go stop him boss with his
bare hands
[Music]
I got to tell you I'm really liking the
tone yeah I'm really liking the tone hey
I got a question for you guys on the
live stream really quick should we watch
the international one right now let's
just see if anyone comes a good work
should go other difference is the
International one like any different
doors is just the same thing on glabrous
head on the live stream right now to ask
them these questions instead no yeah Oh
a lot of people are saying it's
difference laughs people are saying it's
different yeah right international yeah
it's do I guess we're watching the
International trailer too as well oh
I've heard it's dope I've heard it's
really don't me just make sure it's
there yeah there deal with me okay here
we go for this here we go home with a
momento larva bar sign y'all alright bet
yeah because I got some thoughts I got
some thoughts so we've seen the national
now we're going worldwide our vitamin
let's watch this dang bro whoa look at
that new guy who said that's my shoe I
gotta go oh cool amazing these days oh
cool
listen Walsall bathroom yeah happy the
rich the powerful I don't care about us
with pick up a strand lifting their
table scraps
daily ambassadors it tough you gotta use
the stuff they use the world's change
change to wait for me Patrice next
mission we'll call you
kick it a little more mentoring could be
real-ass 6xu it's not a hug them to
scram the tow for you
oh okay good luck out there someone is
collecting stuff in Avengers battles and
building this crazy weapons this is my
chance to prove myself
okay I like that collecting stuff from
the adventure again
what if somebody had died to different
story right because that's on you I
wanted you to be better eight years but
in trouble from those bozos of it's dark
power and it's all bastard red type
shows up it takes you can tear down
everything to put him out of business
we're gonna take everything they got
[Music]
you're not good
do you know em - yeah house tool issue
dude I love the beginning part of this
trailer yeah mommy baby the world yeah I
really like to be getting the whole vlog
thing um that that made the the
International trailer a like way better
for me I know that made a motor better
for me is seeing that time and it makes
me wonder if they shot that on Civil War
day or if they like just you know put
together some fancy at it where they
were able to make it work you know what
I mean yeah if it'll be if the movie
will have some kind of you know
component that involves that or whatever
I'm wondering if like on the day of
Civil War
like when they were filming Civil War if
they shot that as well you know yeah or
spider-man homecoming as opposed to oh
they went back and through and like is
I'm wondering how they did that
exactly you know I mean I wouldn't put a
past into a plan far enough had I don't
remember with what the machinations
would've end of like all the contracting
and stuff but I wouldn't be surprised if
they did yeah and I like all this stuff
with Jon Favreau and their and even like
the little touches of like because it
made it look real and Tom Halle can
really do all these crazy flips and [ __ ]
okay yeah Tom Hall and part of what his
campaign to be spider-man
he would post videos of him doing actual
like gymnastics moves oh why so he could
really do all those flips and stuff so
dad's aspect so in that scene when he
did that backflip I know that was really
him oh yeah yeah
oh man that movie looks so good and I
like all the extra footage we got to
Michael Keaton's vulture no getting a
game or clear define thing of what his
villain is doing taking these parts of
the Avengers battles and assembling a
massive weapon makes sense why he's such
a like an important threat so I like the
aspect more of Tony Stark like kind of
what's the word for it it's really late
here again the work for not really under
he's under estimating he's under
estimating vulture and seeing like let
someone else take care of this guy you
know
as opposed to and it seems like
spider-man's the only one who's really
focused on we got to take this guy down
you know or or he's under estimating
spider-man is saying like we got dudes
much bigger than you for this like don't
get yourself hurt you know I yeah stay
down like go do your thing maybe that's
not gonna fly this time maybe spider-man
is truly extraordinary cannot be
confined in the neighborhood right and
in that whole sequence to when he had
the the suit on to suit the the tie yes
got a suit on he had a suit up hey man
Ron coming home coming out of the
homecoming always like maybe he's gonna
kiss us and dad I had before he does
that yeah they kiss I mean he's gonna
have some tongue was in deaf probably he
was gonna touch her nipples I don't not
like without a couple shirts in the way
and you know the general like
happenstance like if I could add it on
the dance floors what I'm thinking out
there none of this film but I'm loving
the tone I'm loving the tone of the
whole thing and for anyone who just
tuned into this live stream yeah we
watched the domestic and the
international trailer just now because I
see comments coming in um yeah I really
love the whole tone of of what we're
getting it's the one thing that's making
this feel like this can be unique
spider-man experience it's the only
thing that's really doing it for me back
with Tom Hollands performance of course
well Tom about like Peter Parker's is
consistently the thing that gets me like
really excited about this movie and each
of these trailers gave me even more of
that like yeah and that's what you know
anchors the story and I'm really excited
to revisit it now where I wasn't even I
wasn't like jacked when Amazing
Spiderman came out like I was interested
but like now I'm actually excited again
and uh you know they're updating it it's
gonna take me a minute to kind of
process the whole like Oh spider-man
suit is like Jarvis yeah um but and you
know they're they're really updated the
vulture and stuff like that so I'm
interested to see now what the mechanics
of their world had to be you know oh and
the stuff with spider-man suit kind of
being under Tony's control like he's a
little limited with the suit that's why
that's why I seem like Peter was
tampering with the suit trying to figure
it out but his friend was Ned was like
its blocked by all these codes by Starr
but yeah the training wheels perk I said
because it was a cool touch to see all
the additions that the suit has as I was
wondering what are all the real
additions that the suit has a Tony added
for him and seeing that it's actually
kind of uh you know more sci-fi suit has
all these technological advancements
that allow him to see more and do more
it's like Batman's belt it's like Batman
is rebelled yeah exactly but at the same
time it has restrictions on it yeah so
the Tony controls and it looks like
there's gonna be a fair amount of Iron
Man in this film oh really I'm here's
only in a few scenes okay and I'm pretty
sure the shredder showed us all those
scenes yeah they look like a few keys
yeah I'm pretty sure they did um okay
would sell let's look at a couple we
really look at a couple comments we're
going to call it a night nipple day um
yeah it'll be like uh you know one on a
good quality camera of us talking about
this soon
spider-man homecoming our thor ragnarok
i'm still more excited for thor ragnarok
actually to be honest I were to compare
the two I would go Thor Ragnarok
yeah just cuz like I don't know there's
there's just uh something that seems so
wild about Ragnarok that I really want
to go check out and it seems like
they're really taking a bold opportunity
with that one in this one they kind of
just have to execute spider-man properly
yeah exactly and so which it looks like
they're doing yeah I mean I think it's
great that because I feel as much as
this needs to be its own standalone film
and not be all about connecting to the
Avengers it looks like because
spider-man's finally in the MCU that all
the connections to the Avengers are
what's making this film even more unique
in terms of oh camera cut because it's
connected to the MCU and that's been the
whole big deal is that spider-man is
finally in it that having him that that
it's one of the like normally when I see
all these Avengers references I can get
a little tired of you know universe
building crap when it's like really in
my face especially in try
litters but for spider-man it kind of
doesn't bother me because I'm like we
got a bunch of solo spider-man movies
where it's not the MCU I don't mind if
they're going out or a way to really
connect more you better remember to the
Avengers throw an Iron Man in there and
stuff and I still hope that the majority
of it makes it feel like its own
standalone piece yeah but it's still I'm
okay with all the references that are
happening yeah I feel like they've
gotten more natural over time with how
they incorporate how they basically make
the Avengers world a pretty big world
where you just kind of hear about the
different characters from time to time I
feel like they've gotten either they've
gotten more natural at it or I've just
gotten more used to it but I feel like
they're better at it now Oh total where
you just kind of accept the reality and
it's it's a little less hammy than it
used to be you know let's see there's
one more comment here okay we're looking
for the next great comment to go off of
there we're gonna call it a night
who's Donald Glover I had no idea he was
in oh yeah well that counts coming in
too fast oh gosh
Greg can't really see them like thank
you thank you for the schmoes spider-man
or Justice League spot spider-man dots
and the fries spider-man actors yeah
we've talked about we're looking for a
comment that get extra spark and you
thought that we never said I'd like to
uh shingen's doc Donald Glover is miles
is uncle is that true is that true can
you guys confirm that we should do more
live reactions since the status guys
directly good-looking fat easily is that
you Donald Glover really is okay before
say no obviously Michael Keaton's son I
was gonna be pretty excited for that and
honestly I mean I'm seeing a couple of
comments here asking about I guess we'll
go off on this four people are like
who's your favorite Toby Andrew or Tom
and honestly um you know I I have yet to
decide where Tom Holland ranks for me
because I only saw 20 minutes a minute
in one movie it looks great in the
trailer don't get me wrong
but to be to be putting that question
out there like who's your favorite
spider-man like yeah you know not Tom
Hollands around he's an official new
spider-man I need to see at least one
feature film before I break my spider in
here yeah yeah I mean I always have a
soft spot in my heart for forty McGee
but uh yeah you know I I don't a lot of
people bag on Andrew Garfield for those
movies but I don't think he's the
problem I think Andrew Garfield's great
yeah I think like mazing yeah I get that
he's a different kind of Peter Parker
but I still thought he did a good job
and he endeared me in those movies but
yeah I'm definitely in the train with
you like Tom Holland looks like he could
be terrific and I just need to see this
movie before I can tell that yeah
totally totally
cuz cuz cuz spider-man I feel like is
kind of like you could have the same
debate that we do about Batman is like
who's got it all who does a good editor
Parker and a spider-man and both
together and like you know III know that
there's some complaints from like
spider-man fans about like ah you know
the Tobey Maguire version isn't so much
this and the Andrew Garfield version
isn't so much that and so maybe Tom
Holland will be the perfect yeah look it
comes down more than just their
performance though it really comes down
to what this writing and especially what
the direction is wanting for a
spider-man movie to be tow as opposed to
just putting it on the actor because
actors most actors go under what's the
director's vision for the film you know
yeah yeah so they're trying to honor or
whatever it is the directors trying to
do and work with them as well creatively
did you say like The Breakfast Club
meets the event yeah you're saying uh
what's the director John John you John
Hughes yeah um I love that hey where are
you guys where are you guys from we'll
put this out of the the video when we
upload it but where are you guys from
what like country who's that who's not
in the United States I want to see who's
not us Sully does this is Ethan Eddie
say that Sully does this the Mexico cuz
Scotland's an air shield Indonesian Anna
Australia Argentina Canada Finland
Thailand
this is great romper Oh Jeremy you know
when you go to like the analytics
Finland Saudi Arabia awesome San
Fernando Valley neverland's Eurovision
Algeria English guy awesome Poland Rio
novo my god me so exciting thank all
your gaming isn't watching my Sony dos
ángeles Jakarta North Pole Switzerland
which I don't know I can't show up
anyone's is recommending different
countries from California Germany and
only okay
Mars oh my god hey and on all the people
who are in the United States this is the
best because last it's crazy this is the
Internet in a microcosm right here cuz
all you have to do is ask a question the
first wave is like people actually
answering you and the second wave is
people trying to answer also yeah third
wave adding Mars and then fourth
Malaysia chaos people of Mexico New
Zealand oh my gosh China that is crazy
it's crazy what YouTube is doesn't it
people isn't a nut sandwich isn't a nuts
oh man oh yeah and if they just cross
this over with venom from Tom Hardy's
Tom Hardy venom will have a perfect
spider-man universe wait a minute guys
Tom Holland is spider-man Tom Hardy is
yeah just like how Tobey Maguire and
Topher Grace lime is similar spider-man
we're really ending this all right yeah
yeah it's about time we're gonna do this
thing I'm sorry if we missed a question
that you kept asking I apologize this we
can't see them all at once Oh like they
just keep coming in love you guys thank
you to everyone from all the crazy
countries are tuning in from thank you
for tuning in for everyone in the States
thank you for tuning in as well whoever
is up with us in the States this late at
night
thank you you can if you if you're new
to the channel subscribe and also if you
subscribe put down
that you subscribe if it's this video
that made you subscribe put it down
talking to you on the livestream talking
to you on the camera put that
notification cook that notification belt
and notify whenever videos out John is
Det John Humphrys on Twitter and
Instagram go check out our patreon for
all our exclusive goodies on their
exclusive video content and all this
other awesome rewards much love to
everyone out there thank you for
everyone to tune in to the live stream
and if you didn't get a chance to catch
a live stream I don't blame you it's
1:30 in the morning good night
it's late you're not types odds it's
later or earlier